primer debate presidencial en eeuu
marcado por intensos cruces acusaciones
y ataques personales el presidente de
donald trump y sus contendientes
demócrata joe by the end se midieron en
un encuentro repleto de interrupciones y
agresiones en el que ya es considerado
como el debate más caótico en la
historia del país ampliaremos desde
washington cuarto día de combates en el
conflicto del disputado territorio de
nagorno karabaj entre las fuerzas de
azerbaiyán y de armenia ahora el consejo
de seguridad de naciones unidas pidió un
cese al fuego inmediato y rusia se
ofreció como mediador pero armenia
rechaza la oferta
y bélgica tiene nuevo gobierno de
coalición tras 16 meses de haber
celebrado elecciones parlamentarias y de
no llegar a un acuerdo que permitiera un
gobierno estable siete partidos
acordaron una alianza liderada por el
líder alexander de croo actual ministro
de finanzas ampliaremos estas noticias
desde bruselas
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 saludamos a nuestra
audiencia muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos como siempre soy santiago
ariztía y comenzamos esta emisión en
eeuu y es que donald trump y joe biden
se enfrentaron por primera vez en un muy
intenso debate desde cleveland ohio el
presidente republicano interrumpió
permanentemente al candidato demócrata
por lo que dominó toda la transmisión
realizada por la cadena 'fox reconocida
por su tendencia conservadora los
intercambios más beligerantes se dieron
en torno a temas como la composición de
la corte suprema- el pago de impuestos
la gestión de la pandemia de coronavirus
kobe 19 también la economía y por
supuesto también las protestas contra el
racismo policial veamos el resumen de la
noche en el siguiente informe
marcado por interrupciones y acusaciones
mútuas transcurrió el primer debate
presidencial
el mandatario reiteró que le
correspondía a él nominar al sucesor de
la fallecida ruth báder ginsburg
mientras que biden pidió esperar a que
haya un nuevo presidente para hacer la
confirmación argumentando el temor de
que la nominación de amy cón y barber
hecha por trump ponga en peligro el
acceso a la salud asequible permitido
por el obama que en plena pandemia
en esta hora en la corte suprema-
tratando de deshacerse del obamacare lo
cual le quitaría a 20 millones de
personas su seguro de salud
lo que derivó a la discusión del cob y
19 estamos a semanas de una vacuna
estamos haciendo terapias - personas
están muriendo cuando se enferman muchas
menos personas mueren hemos hecho un
gran trabajo lo único que ha sido muy
trabajo que eso es por las noticias
falsas sin importar lo que uno les diga
ellos dan mala prensa estas noticias
falsas
este es el mismo hombre que dijo que
para la pascua el virus desaparecería
cuando el clima caliente empezará
seguiría como
agro y a propósito tal vez podrías
inyectar un poco de cloro en tu brazo y
eso lo acabaremos los impuestos de trump
tema que preveía sería clave tras las
revelaciones del 'new york times' según
las cuales no habría pagado nada en 11
años pasó casi de largo
usted nos dirá que tanto pagó en
impuestos en 2016 y 2017 millones de
dólares usted pagó millones de dólares
millones de dólares millones de dólares
y usted podrá verlo y usted llegará a
ver lo son responsabilizó a los
demócratas de los desmanes registrados
al margen de las protestas contra la
violencia policial el racismo
estructural mientras que el
exvicepresidente evitó a arremeter
contra la policía que esta protesta
política pacífica cuando van por la
mitad de la ciudad y acaban con las
tiendas matan gente por todas partes eso
no es pacífica
él es racista hace mucho más sobre esto
el hecho es que hay insensibilidad
racial la gente tiene que ser consciente
de lo que sienten los demás de lo que
los insultan
entre las acusaciones de la noche trump
dijo que biden era un títere de la
izquierda radical a lo que el
exvicepresidente respondió que él era un
títere del presidente ruso vladimir
putin y vamos ahora a washington para
ampliar la información con diana
castañeda corresponsal de france 24
dianas muy buenos días contanos cómo
amaneció el país después de este debate
tan particular qué repercusiones se
viven allí
bueno pues los comentarios al interior
de las redes sociales por parte de los
demócratas y por ejemplo en cabeza de la
encargada de la cámara de representantes
nancy pelosi pues muestran o piden que
no se haga un segundo debate ya que el
presidente de donald trump no puede
seguir las reglas de esto debido a que
en varias oportunidades podemos ver cómo
interrumpía incluso al moderador
pero también hay críticas a como el
presidente aseguró no defender a los
supremacistas blancos o dio una
respuesta no muy clara al respecto y
esto encabeza los principales titulares
de la prensa sobre todo porque en las
redes sociales muchos grupos
supremacistas blancos salieron a
defender la respuesta del presidente de
donald trump por su parte bardem aseguró
que esta es una representación de lo que
el presidente de donald trump quiere
mostrar a la nación y es un presidente
que divide que crea conflicto y no
alguien que brinda soluciones y por
supuesto también hay muchos titulares
alrededor
la crisis de el coronavirus las
respuestas del presidente y los ataques
personales entre los dos el golpe más
bajo como califica la prensa desde para
ataque del presidente donalson hacia el
hijo de joe par que podemos esperar para
el próximo debate el segundo para el que
nos falta mucho y además sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta este antecedente tan
particular no
así es es un debate que se espera tenga
la misma dinámica donde el público pues
tenga que tomarse una prueba de
coronavirus para poder asistir será un
público menor de 70 personas la mayoría
de esos estudiantes de la universidad de
eso decir en youtube y básicamente pues
este será el escenario perfecto para
discutir temas de la plataforma si se
puede llegar a realizar un debate entre
kamala harris y el vicepresidente pensé
en donde no haya tantos ataques pues que
muestren sus plataformas sobre todo para
los más jóvenes por eso escogieron este
escenario de la universidad de utah y
también para llegar a los votantes de la
costa este de los eeuu que tienen muchas
preguntas sobre la recuperación
económica igualmente se espera pues que
en este debate se den las mismas pautas
de discusión que sean segmentos de 15
minutos 6 segmentos en total y lo que
toca esperar para ver si los dos
candidatos a la vicepresidencia tendrán
digamos un sentido o un compromiso más
amplio para poder discutir sus
plataformas
y quedarse en la discusión que
partidista gracias diana castañeda por
este reporte desde washington estados
unidos avanzamos con más noticias porque
el conflicto en el tan disputado
territorio de nagorno karabaj entra ya
en su cuarto día de intensos combates
entre las fuerzas de azerbaiyán y de
armenia el consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas pidió un cese del fuego
inmediato una petición de la que rusia
se hizo eco y ya se ofreció como
mediador pero armenia rechazó esta
oferta alegando que los combates no son
una atmósfera adecuada para los diálogos
durante la noche y el día los combates
continúan en nagorno karabaj los
intensos enfrentamientos entre los
separatistas apoyados por armenia y los
azerbayanos han provocado docenas de
muertes
incluyendo a varios civiles sin poder
establecer un balance preciso la noche
del martes el consejo de seguridad de la
onu se reunió en una sesión de
emergencia en una declaración unánime
los 15 miembros pidieron el cese
inmediato de los combates el consejo de
seguridad expresa su apoyo al
llamamiento del secretario general a
ambas partes para que pongan fin a los
combates de inmediato calmen las
tensiones y reanuden sin demora las
negociaciones constructivas rusia está
tratando de activarse en el frente
diplomático el presidente ruso habló
esta misma noche con mi corpacci nyan el
primer ministro de armenia pidiendo un
alto el fuego
moscú también está tratando de contener
a turquía un aliado de azerbaiyán
armenia descartó una intervención rusa o
internacional para negociar un bacchus
alegando que no hay una atmósfera
adecuada de requisito para las
conversaciones para china también dijo
estar preparado para una intervención
militar en ankara
acusa del derribo de uno de sus aviones
militares y armenia armenia y los
armenios de nagorno karabaj están ahora
tras el accidente el caza f 16 euros por
expuestos a una amenaza directa de
turquía van a ser según nuestros datos
turquía busca un pretexto para
intervenir aún más en este conflicto
conflicto
acusaciones refutadas por turquía pero
también por azerbaiyán turquía nos
ofrece apoyo moral pero turquía no
participa de ninguna otra manera
en todo el mundo la ansiedad está
creciendo parís berlín y washington han
pedido sin éxito un cese de las
hostilidades inmediato
familiares de ciudadanos hongkoneses
detenidos por autoridades chinas
marcharon para exigir su pronta
liberación y también el acceso a
abogados defensores que no sean elegidos
por el gobierno chino se trata de 12
ciudadanos que fueron arrestados el
pasado 23 de agosto por la guardia
costera de china cuando interceptaron un
barco que viajaba desde hong kong a
taiwán tras una ofensiva contra
activistas prodemocracia los 12 se
encuentran actualmente detenidos en la
ciudad de jensen por su parte el joven
activista prodemocracia hong kong es yo
yo won recientemente arrestado y
liberado instó a no rendirse frente a lo
que considera una presión por parte de
las autoridades de china
un día antes del día nacional chino creo
que no es momento de celebrar con la
dura campaña impuesta por las
autoridades de beijing y con el
presidente si queriendo silenciar las
voces de los hongkoneses tenemos que
lanzar una señal clara al mundo incluso
si tratan de arrestarnos enjuiciarnos o
incluso encerrarnos en prisión no hay
razón para rendirnos avanzamos con
noticias del continente europeo porque
tras 16 meses de haber celebrado
elecciones parlamentarias y de no llegar
a un acuerdo que permitirá un gobierno
estable de coalición entre partidos
liberales socialdemócratas conservadores
y también ecologistas bélgica tiene ya
un nuevo primer ministro se trata del
liberal alexander de croo actual
ministro de finanzas del país quien va a
sustituir a la primera ministra en
funciones
sophie güelmes cuyo mandato interino
finaliza precisamente mañana y nos
acompaña desde bruselas nuestra
corresponsal esther herrera hola esther
bueno ha costado mucho no formar este
gobierno ya sabemos ahora quién lo va a
liderar se trata de alexander de croo
contanos quién es él
buenos días así es han sido
cuatrocientos noventa y tres días de
negociaciones hasta formar un gobierno
es decir un año y medio en que varias
veces han estado al borde de la ruptura
pero aunque bélgica está bastante
acostumbrada de hecho tiene un récord ya
en 2011 en que tardaron más de 500 días
en formar al gobierno el nuevo ejecutivo
está liderado por un joven político
alexander de croo de 45 años pero que ya
es conocido aquí en bélgica porque como
comentaba si había sido el primer
ministro del anterior gobierno ministro
de finanzas y también ministro de
cooperación y de desarrollo de hecho
justamente como ministro de cooperación
en múltiples ocasiones había había dicho
que él era un ministro feminista que
estaba a favor de la igualdad entre
hombres y mujeres y justamente cuando
donald trump retiró la ayuda a los
países en desarrollo por la
planificación familiar
alexander de croo junto con el gobierno
holandés fue uno de los que promovió una
nueva plataforma para ayudar a las
mujeres en estos países además dentro de
la coalición se va a introducir un
concepto nuevo en el código penal de
feminicidio algo que no existía hasta
ahora y forma parte de estas
negociaciones tan intensas estar
contándonos cuáles son los retos que
tiene por delante el nuevo primer
ministro
lo cierto es que este gobierno no lo va
a tener nada fácil porque tienen va a
tener una durísima oposición por parte
del partido nacionalista flamenco
incluso también la ultraderecha que
aseguran que este gobierno es totalmente
legítimo también hasta la lucha contra
la pandemia bélgica ha superado las
10.000 muertes y además los contagios no
paran de subir en grandes ciudades como
bruselas o ander es gracias a este por
este reporte en otras noticias bajo el
nombre de siente como en casa dior
presentó el primer gran desfile en la
industria de la moda tras el
levantamiento de las restricciones por
el brote de coronavirus durante la
semana de la moda de parís
esta marca exhibe una colección de ropa
mucho más cómoda
la semana de la moda de parís se muestra
más exclusiva que nunca que este año la
asistencia al desfile de dior estuvo
limitada a 300 personas contrario a los
miles que suelen asistir habitualmente
este fue el primer espectáculo
presencial tradicional que lleva
adelante una casa de modo importante de
parís desde el confinamiento impuesto en
la primavera y resultó más silencioso de
lo que están acostumbrados los invitados
yo creo que está perdiendo un poco de su
estilo es un poco triste todo el
folklore de la semana de la moda ya no
existe los eventos los abrazos
un eco del encierro en la pasarela las
modelos presentaron una colección con un
estilo de pijama suelto y fluido una
prenda adecuada para vestir y pasar
meses en espacios interiores
rabat life tenemos más vida privada
menos vida social entonces nuestra
relación también con la ropa es
completamente diferente porque creo que
podría ser más personal más en relación
con nuestro cuerpo con nuestro
sentimiento we were feeling el evento se
vio interrumpido por un infiltrado del
movimiento rebelión contra la extinción
con una pancarta un recordatorio que la
industria de la moda produce el 10 por
ciento de todas las emisiones de carbono
de los humanos y es el segundo mayor
consumidor del suministro de agua en el
planeta y de esta manera finalizamos
otra emisión informativa pero los
invitamos a continuar informándose en
france mit y cuatro.com así podrán
acceder a las últimas noticias de
américa latina y del resto del mundo ya
los programas realizados por nuestros
periodistas expertos
como le decíamos finalizamos otra
emisión de noticias pero quédense con
nosotros porque hay mucho más en el
resto de nuestra programación y como les
decíamos en france24 punto com
[Música]